Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait.
Stop down, let's do our bid.
Let's do our bid first.
Wow, guys.
Where is Min?
What?
Oh my god.
Whoa.
There you are.
Here she is.
She's in the corner.
Call there.
Oh, freaky.
Oh, yeah, Min is really quiet because she doesn't have her
set up.
Wait, I'm like so loud on my head.
No, no, you're real.
I told you, I said you were like really quiet earlier.
I don't worry, I turned you up on Discord.
Wait, hold on.
I mean, is this better?
I don't know.
I'm really bad at reading the audio mixer.
That's why I'm audio guys.
I don't know what, I don't know.
I just, I go by feel.
I go by feel.
I'm like, you're just, to me, I'm like, you seem quiet.
I can't go up any higher.
I can, though.
Oh, I can go higher.
No, yours is like, is like super quiet.
Also, like, my lurches are on top of you.
Dad's just dancing on top of your head.
I, I, I will say I hate, I, okay, I've had so many issues
with so many, what's the words?
What's the word?
Interfaces?
Yeah.
And the Go XLR is what's annoying me.
So bad.
Yeah, the mini one.
Yeah, I have the mini one.
Yeah, I just like, I bought, what is it called?
I bought the Elgato mic.
You know, you saw it.
I brought it at the, like, the, remember when we were doing
the concert thing?
I brought it during the, for the concert, the Phantom Peep
concert, the Elgato, the little small Elgato mic.
I just used that.
because that has its own built-in interface it's not great
but it's not obviously so does the so does the go xlr but
it's so terrible i don't know oh really yeah yeah okay i
have you up i have you have a 0.0 db that's i think that's a
lot better is it better i'm not sure can you guys hear me is
it better guys yeah i have her a 0.0 i cannot go any higher
Yeah, so for the I think I can I can go higher too.
I can go higher too.
No, I don't I think that I actually Everyone say it's a lot
better.
I don't know if you're too loud or anything.
Oh my gosh.
I almost I had like a little I almost fucking pushed my
bottle now.
I'm too loud now.
I'm loud.
Wait, I can hold on Is this better is this better?
I think you're too quiet now.
We go back to go back in between Hello.
Hello.
Hello, hello.
Is it good?
people were saying it was fine before yeah so i had to make
sure because i was like now guy is is oh yeah some yeah
she's like yeah now she's too loud okay so i had to make
sure i asked min like do they know you're not at home just
in case yeah my setup is all wackadoo everything that's why
her she sounds very different because she's not at home
right now she is traveling we're is made phantome bring her
down okay i'll bring you i'll bring her down a little you're
never gonna bring me oh
my gosh anyway okay all right guys today we are playing
metal gear solid delta snake eater this is a game picked by
a fellow dragon for winning one of the charity Yeah, this is
a, I honestly have no idea any of the lore of the Metal Gear
main series.
I know I played Metal Gear.
What?
Do you know which game this is like in the chrono, like in
the order of like one, two, three, four, five?
Like, isn't this a third game?
Wouldn't it be the third game in the order?
Is it not one, two, three, four?
Like, is it not chronological?
No.
What's the fuck?
Why the fuck?
Why is it not chronological?
This is the third game in the series.
But it's the first game in the timeline.
Why didn't say, like, why is it not like Metal Gear Zero?
Why is it Metal Gear Delta?
Metal Gear Solid 3.
Yeah, but if it's the third game, but it's a prequel, then
why won't they just call it Metal Gear Zero?
Because...
Or Metal Gear Prequel.
Because Zero is not the main character.
Snake is.
So is this Metal Gear Solid Snake?
null wait how is naked snake how is there more than one
snake I well that's what you're maybe gonna find out
actually you don't find out I think in this game okay wait
who am I playing a naked snake you're naked snake wait no
are you fuck no no you're baiting me there's no way there's
name is naked snake there's play about metal gear dokeybird
why would i ever lie about you're here you're here for the
yowie oh my god did you see the tweet about how i did not
realize yowie is not pronounced yowie it's pronounced yowie
or something oh yeah the person they were like this is how
westerners say there's a different pronunciation for to
yowie
I was like, what the fuck is y'all?
Oh, yeah, boy.
Yeah, boy.
I feel like I'm a, every time I say yaoi, I feel like I'm
like Tom and Jerry.
Yeah.
Like something stepped on my toe, like little Tom or little
Jerry dropped like a brick on my toe and I go.
Yeah.
All right.
you know english oh okay it's english and japanese i was
like wondering if if we play espagno if he starts speaking
spanish i was gonna say yeah i don't think it's dub so
unfortunate it would have been pretty funny would have been
hilarious oh i bought the deluxe version because i want to
be a crocodile oh yeah that's a good idea that's a good idea
yeah yeah don't worry i bought the broken windows who wants
the highest graphics i don't know i would do balance i don't
know if my I always pick balance Yeah, I do have a stuff
makes it kind of Yeah, that's what I'm also afraid of I do
have a 59 but I don't know Kojima always surprises me
Kojima's not a part of this Oh, he's not?
Don't mention his, no Oh, wait, oh yeah Cause this is a
remaster of his game That he made, oh yeah, sorry Yeah,
yeah, yeah Alright It is fine Oh god, it's so red It's fine
or it's just like a flashbang oh wait don't they play the
intro in the beginning of this one i think no wait i don't
think so please play in a well-lit room while sitting or
standing as far away from the he's gonna say the thing the
game contains expressions and themes which may be considered
outdated oh my god is there racism in this game yeah what
did he mean by outdated how bad is the racism what was the
outdated stuff I can't remember.
I was like, usually when they say that.
I can't remember.
It's not that bad.
All right.
Naked ammunition belt.
Gold crocodile.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, my God.
You gotta put on the masks, too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
How do I put it on?
Snake.
Oh, this is my favorite part.
You have to start the game.
You have to start the game to put it on.
There's a food collection.
Oh, my God.
Wait, what if I play snake versus monkey?
Sometimes you might shit your pants.
Oh, oh.
This is a different game, by the way.
This is not the main game, but there's monkeys in this game.
It's literally called snake versus monkey.
It's not called Metal Gear Solid Delta Snake Eater.
I thought it was like the subtitle of a subtitle.
I'm sorry, but we need it.
Something big is going down.
Very big.
Oh my god.
It's actually really fun, though.
up game up a little bit mint down a little bit all right i
got you don't silence me all right too late damsel in
distress i'll think about it well it's not quite a oh i'm
gonna rescue the monkeys but it is a rescue yeah you gotta
rescue the monkeys the apes that escaped So you don't know
this, but the guy you're talking to is not even like from
this era.
Is he dead or alive?
He's alive, but he's like this guy that is talking to him is
not supposed to know him.
Wait, who's not supposed to know who?
Does Snake know him?
Snake?
Snake is not supposed to know the Colonel that you're
talking to.
Okay, but he knows me.
Not yet.
It's like a time How would he how does he not know snake?
He's there.
He's metal gear solid Don't say that he's John metal gear.
Yeah, he's literally John metal gear It's like so it's like
him not knowing who James Bond is.
How does he not know who I am?
Isn't this just some monkey catching action snake?
I'm asking monkey catching action.
It's a request from the professor himself Who's the
professor?
Natalie who the fuck is Natalie?
The one who came up with the monkey helmet the monkey helmet
I was like, yeah.
There's no context for clues for any of this.
He's Otacon's friend too.
Oh, is Otacon Ocelot?
That Otacon has been able to come up with.
Otacon is Otacon.
Why would Otacon be Ocelot?
Don't be burned.
Use your brain.
Why would they be the same person?
I don't know.
Maybe he's like the father of Ocelot.
Because they both start with, oh.
No, the father of Ocelot.
Atacon, Acelot.
It rhymes.
Atacon is not even alive right now.
He's like not even alive.
He's dead.
Why did you smell that for me?
He's a single-celled organism at this moment.
He's a sperm right now.
He's not even been born yet?
No.
Wait, then who's his dad?
Whose sperm is it?
Acelot?
For who?
for Osalad is Otacon's dad they have to have like a awesome
name yeah yeah it's like uh to carry on the bloodline your
name has to yeah yeah yeah yeah all right escape from the
jungle i just want to take a monkey yeah it's actually
really fun i like it is mm-hmm oh my look at him i got so
excited when i saw this in the Whatever trailer it was, the
Game Award trailer.
And like Snake does really funny poses.
Oh my god, I have a banana!
Alright, I got him.
Grab him, grab him!
How do I- Oh my god, he fucking punched me!
I told you to grab him!
I'm trying!
What the fuck is the grab button?
He's just punching me in the dick!
Why don't you know the basics of seeing the sea donkey?
I don't know how to play this game!
Okay, I don't have to roll.
Okay, I know how to- I'm proning, I'm proning, I got a nice
view too.
Remember the basics of CQC, it's so sad.
Grab him.
I shot him.
Oh, okay, I have to shoot him.
Okay, I got it, I got it.
There you go.
Okay, you should have told me I just had to shoot him.
I don't know, I'll figure it out.
Oh, you're not a very good backseat it.
I never said I was gonna be backseat.
Wait, how do I okay?
Wait, I can wait, I got this.
I'm gonna lay down lay laid laid Down girl down.
Okay, give me a sec.
Keep trying.
Okay, all right.
Okay.
Here you go.
Here you go I'm I'm backing up.
I'm backing up Yeah, it's like parking.
It's like parking, you know How could you miss?
He was right?
It has a shield!
I'm parallel parking right now.
I'm just parallel.
What the fuck?
He's just climbing up.
Oh my god.
Yeah, because he's a monkey.
I know.
Will he fall down?
Oh, they do wake up, by the way.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, gotcha.
Okay, I gotta figure this out.
Oh, there we go.
Got you?
There you go.
I still don't know which one's prone.
Okay, I figured it out.
All right, I need it.
Good job.
I need three more.
Four more I can't count.
Four more.
Can't count, everybody.
She miscounted the intro too.
Morning.
No, it's not morning.
Oh, my God.
I'm dying.
What do you mean morning?
I'm already dead.
Oh, there he is.
Look at him.
There's a guy right there.
He's just eating.
He was eating.
now that's where I got you all right gotcha three more well
we can I actually follow no okay oh not a test wait I oh my
god I'm lagging so hard oh wait I can take pictures yeah
it's really good all right I gotta get better pose for this
oh in here that's right reflex right in the air Wait, this
is an FPS game.
Why am I using a controller?
It's not FPS.
Oh, you got it in a box.
How is it not an FPS?
I'm literally shooting him.
Are you in first person?
Oh, it's a TPS.
This is a TPS game.
Oh, hey, AstroBot.
It's your favorite.
I know.
This game was mid for me.
Wait.
Gamers don't look up.
What the fuck?
But how did you know?
Because I played this.
Oh, it's like they're the same pose all the time.
Yeah.
Oh, it's because the Astro Bot.
The Astro Bot thing.
Oh my god, the record was one minute.
Because like in Astro Bot, he was in the tree.
I remember because I remember that clip of you freaking the
fuck out.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, let's get this down a little.
little too high but i'm at 60 frames how the fuck is it that
all right medium are you lagging oh my god yeah i am i gotta
turn this turn motion blur off we'll do medium oh that was
just like a a test you know we did the mini game first to
test out the frame rate yeah the graphic settings and
everything all right now oh wait there's subtitles oh yeah
well yeah you'll want those on 100%.
Let's make it big in-game subtitles.
So I know if people know I'm there.
Oh, I should have their names on, too.
Because I don't know who any of them are.
Oh, yeah.
And I do that, too.
It's helpful.
All right.
I wish more games would allow that, honestly.
Yeah, honestly.
Because, like, what if, like, I just have zero context about
everything?
Like, how am I supposed to know their names?
Like now.
Yeah, like now.
Okay, here we go.
I'm playing the Metal Gear Solid series for the first time.
For the first time.
Yeah.
Aiming is done in first person view freely, which is better.
First person or third person?
I mean, I get to see his ass more.
You still get to aim.
Yeah, you get to aim in first person in the legacy.
in first person and new style too if you switch it so it's
like not it's not you can pick whichever one okay people are
saying new is better all right it's it is easier like the
sea style okay so european extreme why do the europeans have
their own game mode like you should oh wait you should do
that one you should do that one i thought it's locked what
do you mean game over upon being detected by the enemy it'll
be like the fastest stream i get died from the first person
and they were like, all right, three's over, guys.
But why?
Yeah, that's it.
I like how the Europeans get their own fucking game mode.
Like, yeah.
All right, normal.
They're just feel different.
You all, all right.
Yeah, normal's good.
After the end of World War II, World War II was split into
two.
Which side are we on?
Wait, why can't I see your screen?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, wait, so I had to up the volume a little bit more.
Okay.
Alright.
Konami presents.
Alright, sound guy, up the game a bit more.
Let me know if it's better.
Based on Metal Gear Solid 3.
Yeah.
Whoa.
Which is the good side?
Huh?
So they're like, we're on the good side.
But which one's the good one?
Oh.
Oh
20 minutes to drop off commencing internal depressurization.
Oh my god, Johnny's combat Is that is that solid snake?
Oh, is that auto ocelot?
him yeah that's oscillot wait that's oscillot yeah that's
why it says major above him oh major oscillot yeah exactly
exactly exactly okay that's major that's is that is that
metal gear solid that's metal gear solid yeah john metal
gear connecting oxygen hose put on your mask
no that guy's from that guy is a cameo from ace call combat
oh oh the that guy the guy with the no i meant the guy
that's smoking that's oh yeah that's yeah that's john
meligere and there's osseolot and then osseolot yeah what do
you think the girl's name is i don't know jenny wait there's
wait there's female characters in meligere oh my
That's the only one I remember.
That's the only one you know.
That's the only one I know.
Because like, because the whole fear, the game theory that
the reason why she's like partially naked is because she
needs to breathe through her skin.
That's not the game theory.
That's the real reason.
That's the reason why I remember who quiet is.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
The game theory.
Sorry, the game lore.
That smells good.
The game theory.
Yeah.
Okay, you're about to do something that is like for the
history books.
The world's first.
Oh my god, I'm meeting the Guinness World Records.
10 seconds to drop off.
Yeah, yeah, except not because nobody is allowed to know
that this is happening Yeah, but then like later on like
after like, you know, we win the war then like we can I can
be public about it Oh If you win.
Yeah.
If our side wins Yeah The good side right The good side the
good side.
Yeah Oh my god, look at me girl.
I'm doing back lifts and everything Jesus Christ.
USA.
Cideo Kojima.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, I'm younger.
John Metal Gear is younger now.
No, I think this was like five days ago.
No, see, my hair is black now.
It was before, too.
No, I had like a little bit of white hair from the stress.
You know, don't get cocky.
This isn't betraying you.
No, I don't think so.
Right.
So what exactly is this wonderful?
He doesn't keep stressed.
Oh, because he's snake.
He's, no, it's because he's a robot.
He's Metal Gear.
Oh, that's why he's Metal Gear?
Yes.
He has Metal Gear's inside of.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, so he's like an android.
Wait, is he an android or a robot?
Both?
And the East's foremost expert on weapons development.
Oh my god, wait, I want to say Sokolov and his ugly wife.
Wait, why is his wife ugly?
How do you know his wife is ugly?
Because I've seen a picture of her.
The earth was blue.
We're just jealous that you're not his wife.
Well spoken.
I don't think so.
The rocket that carried Yuri Gagarin from orbit is the A1
known as the Vostok.
rocket man sokolov is said to be the man most responsible
for the multi-engine cluster used in so okay sokolov after
yeah held captive he made he's like a rocket scientist that
has been taken hostage by the russians from a lowly
technician to head of a design okay that's quite a success
that's and your job is to go get that guy it seems okay but
is he a good person or a bad person afraid yes You're gonna
ask that about literally everyone and I'll give you the same
answer to literally every single character.
It's just a gap.
You get the family out first and succeeded in sneaking
Sokolov over the Berlin Wall shortly afterwards.
I was the one who- Oh, the space off of real history!
The security on the eastern side.
Yeah.
Oh!
Wait, this is the Cold War!
One piece, but the whole ordeal- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's why people, okay.
Okay, it's like, which side is the good side?
Okay, I get it now.
Yeah.
This is actually, this is actually like a non-fiction game.
He just, I just heard after World War II, so I thought,
like, Kojima invented, like, a new warrior.
Okay, oh, my God, it's Kennedy.
Look at that, that's a real man.
That's a real guy.
I understand now.
Naval blockade to prevent further missile shipments from
reaching Cuba.
Based on a true story.
Oh, my God.
Snake is real.
This is a game based off of...
Yeah, he interviewed a real man.
The Soviet forces went on alert.
There's a documentary, guys.
Melgear's a documentary.
Oh, God.
That's a terrifying...
You played Rising.
This is a really terrifying thought.
The Soviet Union agreed to remove its missiles from Cuba.
And so the world avoided a nuclear holocaust.
But in order to get the Soviets to pull their missiles out,
we had to make a deal.
You mean the one where the US agreed to remove its IRBMs
from Turkey?
No.
Are you excited to play the game?
The Jupiter IRBMs deployed in Turkey were obsolete.
Eventually, right?
I will eventually be able to play, right?
You have like 20 more minutes.
Okay.
I'm just thinking like, okay, I just feel like that the
cutscenes are going to be locked.
I feel like I'm having a history lesson right now.
It's like a lot of info dump.
But eventually, like, it makes sense.
It's just when the first time you play this game, you're
like, what the hell are they talking about?
What the hell was he working on?
Yeah, what was he working on?
At the time, we had no idea.
Look at those blueprints.
We were running out of time.
I think it's either give up Sokolov or...
We take these blueprints and make a real thing and make it
real.
Yeah, yeah, exactly, exactly.
Write it down, guys.
Write it down.
We'll rebuild it.
The next day, I think we're a little late.
Added him over to agents on the eastern side.
Oh my god, he shot him.
I'm screaming, save me.
Save me.
Why did no one save him?
We received some new information on one of our moles.
Just because he's a nerd doesn't mean they don't have
rights.
He was taken back to the research facility and forced to
continue working on the weapon in question.
Nines do not have rights back then.
You're right.
There were lockers back then.
There were lockers.
Yeah, the...
And jocks that played football.
Yeah, the crew nerds, they have it real good.
Lockers are too small to stuff them now.
to do with the weapon i assume we're talking about a secret
weapon so big that khrushchev was ready to pull out of cuba
to get it back he's sokolov still in a facility no according
to our intelligence he's in selino yask a place oh for the
nerd the virgin cliffs perfect place for him are you sure he
has a wife unfortunately yes But it's our best chance to get
him back This mission would never have been possible If he
was still in the research facility This is our last chance
Hotel Wi-Fi Good luck Alright Oh my god can I play the game
now?
Oh my god I get to play Not yet Wait Press R1 Wait why I did
I did
I'm going I'm going to Russia I assume this is Russia right
listen up Jack your mission oh now you can do it now you can
do it oh nice oh my god I'm so immersed right now I know
that's literally you oh my god literally playing ace combat
before that weapon is complete we'll be facing a major
This is Ace Combat, right?
I've never played Ace Combat before, but I've literally
played Ace Combat right now.
The famous game, Ace Combat, where famously you jump out of
the plane and you don't play.
You don't pilot it.
It involves planes and I jumped out of a plane.
you're what the fear is oh my god jenny oh my god quiet oh
sorry quiet why is she wearing clothes she's gonna suffocate
that's why she's dying literally right now that's why she's
not talking yeah she can't speak she has clothes she can't
speak she has clothes on
even with the fuel in the reserve tank we're facing a four
hour time limit if all goes well it shouldn't take more than
a few hours home in time for dinner but if anything goes
wrong you'll be eating dinner breakfast and all the rest of
your meals in the jungle oh no that sounds terrible back for
christmas no he doesn't get to spend the holidays with his
family does he even have no have family he's a robot what he
could have a little robot built that ain't right that ain't
right it'll only contribute to the uprising
whoa superhero landing whoa it's so cool He's Snake.
He's so cool.
And stupid.
He's Metal Gear Snake.
Oh, that's why it's called Solid.
Because it starts with an S.
And his name is Snake.
Hi.
Yeah.
It's abbreviation.
Oh, he's so fucking cool.
Yeah, Snake.
Oh, his middle name is Dave.
David?
Wait, actually, like, yes, but also...
Oh my god, Snake David.
Okay, are you ready to play the game?
Yeah, I'm ready.
You have, like, another 10 minutes.
Oh my god, I am Nick.
I can sell to you!
Snake.
You don't like snakes?
What do you mean?
You've eaten one before, haven't you?
In survival training.
Wait, but what does a naked mean?
I'm glad to hear that.
Like, why can't I just be snake?
Well, you have nothing on you.
You're naked.
You have to get all your stuff, like...
What should I call you?
You have to get all your weapons and everything.
Uh-huh.
I'll be Tom.
Why does he get to be Tom?
This will be...
Because he's British!
Like, I have to be...
Who's snake then?
If I'm naked snake, there has to be an alpha snake.
Snake prime.
No, it's like there has to be...
I'm flying alpha snake.
Because there's snake prime.
Because why do I have two codes?
Like, why does it have to be naked if I can't just be snake?
He's Major Tom and your naked snake.
Yeah, but the major is his fucking rank.
Naked's not my rank.
Okay,
I only have a knife and a tranquilizer gun.
Why didn't you get me a real gun?
Yeah, about the backpack.
Oh, I lost it in a tree on the way down.
That's not good.
I see.
Well, you better go back and get it.
Oh, you get it.
Yeah.
No problem.
I can see it from here.
It's stuck on a branch.
Yeah.
Oh, I can climb.
Stand in front of a tree.
Sometimes.
Yeah, it's gotta have an IV on it.
I'll be monitoring your progress over the radio.
We can't risk violating Soviet airspace, but I'll be in the
gunship.
My frequency is 140.85.
I'll give you a call if I need to talk to you.
You have to memorize that, by the way.
What do you mean I have to memorize all their codecs?
What?
Is there not a list I can pick?
Where the fuck is my cell phone?
Okay, where's my, like, contact list?
No, there's no way.
Okay, give me a sec.
How do I call people?
How do I...
Write it down.
How do I call people?
Oh, my God.
Wait, how do I call people?
Whoa.
I don't know how...
Oh, wait.
Oh, this is, like, the...
Okay, I got food in my stomach.
Is there food?
And then to eat food I have procured.
Wait, how hungry am I?
You're full.
Oh, I'm full.
Okay.
see it says snake where the fuck is the naked part well you
know it's not they don't always they just say snake they
don't always say the naked part how do i call them with your
phone i don't know how do i bring up my phone i would like
to make a call real quick operator operator
Wait, how do I change my?
Oh, I can't change camera.
Down.
Okay, there you go.
Oh, okay.
So there is a contact list.
Okay, I have it.
It's like, oh, wait.
Oh, I can tune it too.
Okay, that's good.
That's good.
There is a...
Only real players tune it every time.
Why the fuck would you do that here?
Are you reading?
Did you just read that?
Yeah.
It says to tune it.
oh my god this takes forever to tune why the fuck would you
do that all right here we go okay be the change stance oh
okay hold it go prone all right and then here i could i wait
i can so i can call all right yeah i felt like it all right
yeah that's your stuff right there let's call him why are
you calling him i don't know i'm up on the tree i want to
tell let him know yeah yes good so the backpack not yet i
just wanted to let him know i did the good job i climbed the
tree you know you went up the tree
see he's proud of me a little bit look at him he's proud of
me climbing the tree yeah walk along the branch and get it
look he said be careful He cares You have your backpack if
you hang from the branch By pressing the action button
Action Alright, here we go Oh wait, I think mine is lagging
Alright Can I like hang down and call him too?
Oh, I'm gonna drive You might get the same thing First you
need to find that backpack you lost on the way down Oh,
okay, he doesn't care now No, I got it I don't care that
you're dangling I was like, look, look, I'm dangling from
the tree Are you watching?
Are you not?
Do you see you see me dangling?
Okay, are you ready to play the game?
It's necessary.
Okay, you have like another five minutes.
Oh, okay.
Your weapons will be displayed in a list on the screen.
From that list, choose the weapon you want to equip and
press the enter button.
For other equipped items, just do the same thing from item.
Got it.
Use the survival viewer.
backpack yep that's right got it are you paying attention
yes after you've been out in the field for a while your
stamina will start to drop wait what your stamina gets too
low that's why you gotta eat you won't be able to shoot i'm
not the perfect human being but i'm not even human i hate to
admit this i hate to admit this dokey but you're not a robot
you can hunt for local flora and you lied you can use either
your tranquilizer gun or your knife it might have been a
prank in front of in front of john metal gear you would lie
to me what will kojima think
i don't think he wants to think of this game don't get too
trigger happy okay any weapons and equipment beyond what
you're carrying now you'll have to find as you go i'll be
right back i'm gonna get water all right who's crazy what
the what's the point of paying taxes at to find my own
weapons operating procedure you can't leave any traces of
your presence no weapons equipment footprints sweat or
bodily waste the same goes for bullets and cartridges too
your presence in enemy territory is already a violation of
international conventions of warfare yeah you can't leave
any waste not how would they know how is they know it could
it could be like poop from an animal you can't let the enemy
yeah yeah there's actually i've grown up in this game and
they never told me anything about it yeah exactly have you
called the major after you threw up just to be sure yeah and
you say you say I flew up what do I do there's a fake death
pill wait how do I get use it you'll you'll see it one be
issued a potassium cyanide capsule tape it to your body so
you can take it when you need to how generous of you use it
if you're taking prison by the enemy it will send you into a
state of false death for a short time oh snake is dead we
did it that's why you got double tap you mean that thing
they put yeah before the mission oh it's in my tooth okay
careful if you remain in a state of false death for too long
nothing will be able to bring you back remember that i'll
keep it in mind you said this was a solo mission right right
i guess that means i can't count on any reinforcements
Correct the mission rests entirely only you baby.
I got this You got this.
Yeah, I don't need backup No, I'll be fine.
Yeah, exactly This is a solo mission That's why I'm John
Snake David as well as recording your mission data Oh,
you're gonna meet quiet.
Oh, that's quiet You will Hello snake.
I'm paramedic nice to meet you paramedic as in a medic I
feel like like he's like he's learning new words every time
He's kind of stupid.
He's like really smart.
I'm really stupid.
It's John Doe.
It's John Metal Gear
He's literally John Metal Gear He has so many names I wasn't
joking, but I'll tell you my name only if you manage to make
it back alive my frequency is 145.73 all right yeah okay
hers does not store it's like kind of special so you have to
memorize her wait but like what does she do for me one four
zero point she lets you save the game oh and she also tells
you about movies oh it's just like kojima yeah yeah yeah she
is she's like kojima she's like my like movie reviews You
like how like he like if he doesn't like the movie review he
just says I watched this movie And if he likes it he's just
like I went to watch this it wasn't a spectacular thing
Showing of the spirit of humans and he doesn't like it I
watched it Wait that's another woman Boss that's right oh
yeah there's there's like at least three women in this game
from the the metal gear guy who big boss no this is the boss
there's several bosses then who well yeah but there's only a
room for one big boss and it's not her no she's the boss
she's the boss okay so there's the boss and big boss yeah
but many things I wanted you to teach me no I taught you
everything you needed to know about fighting technique did
she get my frequency she's working with you on the mission
oh okay techniques sure but what about how to think like a
soldier how to think like a soldier I can't teach you that a
soldier needs to be strong in spirit body and technique and
the only thing you can learn from someone she's so cool in
fact technique doesn't even matter what's most important is
spirit spirit and body are like two sides of a single coin
they're the same thing i can't recognize her voice no who is
she have to figure it out she's pearl from sponge bob listen
to me jack she's pearl she's ha she's Southerd?
Oh my God.
And politics determine who you face on the battlefield.
And politics are a living thing.
She can, like, just not be Southerd?
Yeah, this is like her actual speaking voice.
It's so good.
Worst actors are so good at their jobs.
A soldier has to follow whatever orders he's given.
It's not his place to question why but you're oh I was
thinking about sandy Oh, I think I was like Pros the whale.
I forgot I was like sandy southern I got them confused You
guys she's a little confused I have the spirit you see
spirit's the most important things guys I'm listening I did
listen to Yeah, yeah, yeah.
She said spirit's the most important thing, and I have the
spirit.
Same thing.
Sooner or later, your conscience is going to bother you.
In the end, you have to choose whether you're going to live
as a soldier or just another man with a gun.
There's a saying in the Orient.
Loyalty to the end.
Do you know what it means?
Being patriotic.
It means devoting yourself to your country.
Ooh, USA.
USA.
I wish I was soundboard just so I can do the ego screech.
I have the spirit of a mirror running me.
You guys just too close to the border.
As long as we have loyalty to the end.
there's no point in believing in anything even in those we
love and that's the way a soldier's supposed to think the
only thing we can believe in with absolute certainty is the
mission Jack all right yeah his name's also Jack what is it
wait my name's John Jack snake David Hater yeah the
legendary unit that the boss put together during World War
two was a snake the Cobra unit a group of heroes that
brought the war to an end and saved the world.
As long as you've got a legendary hero backing you up,
you'll be fine.
Isn't that right, Snake?
Yeah.
Oh my god, wait, the boss docks to me!
He heard my real name!
Tom heard my name!
It's good to hear you.
I think he knows.
Well, but paramedic!
She's in the frequency too!
She just docks me!
She's looking up your address right now.
She has my social security number now.
She already got it.
She's already opened up five credit cards.
CQC.
Close quarters combat, huh?
I've been in three braids for the past four years.
I'm probably pretty rusty.
CQC.
Remember the basics of CQC.
What does CQC stand for?
Close quarters combat.
He already just says that.
Oh my god, pay attention.
Damn, there's so much.
They're like fucking Lord dumping me for 20 minutes
straight.
Welcome to battle.
here my frequency is one four one oh my god there's a lot of
frequencies now okay you have to remember this one too so
okay okay why do i have to remember her all right your
mission is to give mr dr sokolov okay avoid heavy combat and
don't let anyone see you or the game will be over because
you picked the european extreme no no i picked normal it was
locked european was locked it switched it's switched all
right i have a knife and a gun he's gonna say the line say
it say the line john say come on here it is commencing
virtuous mission now is that the line oh yeah
Okay, now you have to practice the CQC.
Backpack.
You got your backpacks.
The heavier the weapon, the faster you'll burn stamina.
Okay, so...
Oh, I have...
What the fuck is this?
That's the D-mic.
Oh, okay, so I can hear...
Oh, I can hear the footsteps.
Oh, there's the pill!
Oh, I can't use it.
Oh.
I mean, you could.
Can I?
Yeah, but you only have so many.
Wait, can I get an unequiped stuff?
Okay, I don't need...
Yeah, you have to unequip things.
What does a cigar do?
How do I smoke it?
It's bad for your health, yeah.
But how do I smoke it?
You have to equip them.
Like, these are all in your backpack.
Yeah, that's how you equip stuff.
Okay.
Nice.
So now you just look really cool.
I look so cool, guys.
Leave me.
I look so cool.
That looks so cool, guys.
Ooh, action movie.
Whoa.
Oh, it's like I'm blinking.
Oh, four, three.
It's like you're about to pass out and that's the last thing
you see.
Okay.
Oh, Metal Gear Solid Delta.
Wait, let's put it here.
Oh, there you go.
There you go.
Oh, that's good.
That's good.
Oh, it looks like an album cover.
Oh, I thought you had it.
That's good.
I think you have to hide the menu Guys screenshot this It's
my new album My album's gonna drop soon
So cool Wait how do I Wait wait wait Is there How do I Oh
film grain Oh wait actually Wait wait How do I do the Okay
Oh, there we go.
That's an album cover.
That goes hard.
Right there.
Yeah, is that black?
Wait, can I do black and white fully?
It has to be...
Probably?
It's probably one of the filters.
Oh, it's the filters?
No, but then I don't have the...
Oh, wait.
Okay.
Oh.
There we go.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
There you go.
I got my album covered.
It's straight out of Tesla.
What the fuck, Tesla?
tesla tesla nova yeah tesla nova some soccer some part two
of the thumbnail
yeah it does need the explicit content yeah yeah that's true
you guys can photoshop in there okay wait let me i'll hide
all i hide everything on the OBS so you guys can Photoshop.
What?
Here we go.
Remember to Photoshop the explicit content.
Oh yeah, I gotta do the, where's the chat overlay too.
There you go.
Very clean.
Very clean for you guys.
It's clean.
It's clean now.
It's clean now, guys.
All right, let's put everything back.
I gotta remember where everything is.
Like there's you.
there's me and then there you go all right there you go so
clean nice nice i use photo mode for the first i look like
what the fuck am i doing with my hands like that's for cqc
oh is that cq okay that's the cqc yeah that's he's in cqc
position right all right okay well unequip the equip the
cigar and then put on oh my gosh yeah put on the mask put on
the carotan mask i had okay or the gaako mask they're both
good there you go they don't so what's great is these stay
on during cut scenes oh that's that's good they didn't know
who i was to put on the mask on the ground where there is
where yeah oh that's a snake yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay
wait so like if you lay you can you can get him now kill him
stabs me oh where did he go he turned around turn around
where did he go he's right behind you he's behind you he's
gone behind you he's no he's he's right behind he's got he's
right there oh my god oh my god oh my god oh there he is
there he is there he is there he is he's like i'm parallel
parking i'm here you have to say that you have to perform
the action that is the name of the game all right snake
eater oh my god you're right i am the snake eater how do i
kill him kill him with with your knife you'll You had it.
Ready your knife and then...
Where is he?
Did you see him?
There he is.
Okay, I think someone forgot to put eye holes in this mask.
Wait, that's my gun.
Okay, guys, give me a sec.
I need to...
How do I get my knife out?
But you have it equipped.
It's with your gun.
Okay.
I'm reloading.
Why?
I'm trying to figure it out!
Okay.
Oh, no, my mask!
There you go.
All right.
What's the button?
I think you can equip just your knife.
But what's the button?
I can't...
I don't remember what it is in this game.
Okay.
Is it right trigger or...
No, no.
No, that's the mask button.
Is it RB?
I can't remember.
No, it's not RB.
The RB is literally me in my mask.
Is it the D-pad?
Oh, okay.
No.
Oh my gosh, I can't remember what it is in this game.
Oh, hey, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, there's your knife.
There's your knife.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, now ready it and then.
And then...
Oh.
I'm not tripping.
Okay.
I don't think I'm allowed to do it.
I don't think I'm allowed to stab the snake.
I think he's like...
You can.
It's allowed.
It's encouraged.
Oh, there you go.
I did it.
You have to aim.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god.
He fucking got Thanos.
Yeah.
Okay.
View tips.
You got him.
I got it.
Oh, and I can eat it.
Oh.
Yeah, you can eat it.
Oh my god.
He shot the goat.
He doesn't feel so good no more.
Not the goat.
Oh, I can tranquilize them.
What can I do when they're tranquilized?
When they're alive.
Okay, so you can tranquilize like snakes and then throw it
at the guards and they get scared.
Oh, that's so cool.
All right, let's eat this.
Yay.
Tasty.
yum yum all right all right okay now you can keep going all
right here i go
yep i'm leaving for this next part you're gonna want to
change your outfit oh okay that's good oh i can be the
crocodile now yes yes okay okay do i want to oh save am i
saving saving the game snake yeah yeah save please save
really long things about movie.
You ever heard of Godzilla King of Monsters?
No, what is it?
It's a movie.
You haven't seen it?
Nope.
It's about this monster called Godzilla who grows to an
enormous size in a nuclear test and goes on a rampage in
Tokyo.
Nuclear test, huh?
Then the Marshall Islands must be crawling with giant
monsters right about now.
It's just make-believe.
Maybe that's why my pants have been so tight.
Wait, what?
damn sick he's really into giant monsters i mean who isn't
who isn't man he's a he's a he was into monster girls guys
closer and closer to tokyo obliterating everything in his
path it was originally a japanese movie but they made an
american version too i recommend seeing the original
japanese one if you ever get the chance it's mostly mindless
fun but it's like is this snake That's good.
You don't have to go to Japan.
Whoa.
In 40 years, you might be able to see it in America too.
It might even win awards all across the globe in 60 years.
Oh my God.
How does she know all that?
This is actually new lines that they recorded.
Of course.
Everybody loves Godzilla.
It's just kind of fun.
You sure know a lot about movies.
I don't suppose you're the movie watching type, are you?
Okay, then I'll tell you everything I know.
When the going gets tough, movies can save your life.
It's always good to be able to look at things from a
different perspective when you get in a jam.
That's the magic of movies.
No kidding.
I feel like I'm watching a movie right now.
What do you mean?
This is the game!
Alright, who do I call?
No, you don't call.
was a oh it was telling me to save no he was like remember
to call people and i was like okay oh who said that oh it
was the the tutorial oh well yeah you'll you'll want to call
just because they have funny lines and stuff oh i see okay
raw arrow raw oh there's the crocodile okay okay okay how do
i change my outfit change how do i change it was um was it
right trigger oh yeah you Oh, okay, there you go.
You can work out when in your environment and face to apply
to face paint.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right.
So...
Oh, is there just mummy?
What the fuck?
Oh, no, that's not as good.
Oh, my God.
I can be literally gold.
You can be completely gold.
Can I change the color?
Oh, I can't.
I was going to say, can I change the color of my mask too oh
but then crocodile suit is so good as well oh I have to
equip no no you have it you have it what the fuck who's this
guy you don't recognize him is that John revenge yes that's
John revenge oh that's John revenge that's John revenge okay
it's hard to tell when he doesn't have his cyborg in hand
advancements you know oh yeah yeah you go you know he
actually has a face yeah a little bit yeah yeah so I I
couldn't tell there where's my fucking so your crocodile
like go out go out of the yeah yeah and um yeah it's in your
items so okay and then you equip it oh he just got my
glasses
his eye so now the crocodiles will like they'll fall in love
with you yeah yeah oh yeah so it's they're cute you can just
like i think you might drown no i'm okay
okay oh the water was so shallow i'm just freaking me i'll
drown i literally saw crocodile walking on the water it's a
puddle it's a goddamn puddle no it's a pond it's very
serious okay okay wait will he get closer to me wait i got
an idea yeah yeah hello oh wait there's one here there's
another yeah there's a couple of them all right get it get
I'm getting to get into position right now.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
I gotta wear my hat.
Wait, I gotta maybe I'll wear sunglasses I gotta look
cooler.
I like the oh wait you can't have the yeah I can't have that
I have to have the I could have the froggy mask.
What does it look like?
Oh, yeah, you could always just we're both they're both.
Yeah, they're both amphibians.
It's almost the same thing
you think he knows no he wouldn't know he wouldn't know yeah
look we're friends hello we're friends guys I'm assuming
position oh wait shit you're sinking you're sinking
fine this place is dangerous yeah these are the Russian
jungles man i don't think russia is known for their jungles
man i is literally what they don't teach you in school that
russia has jungles okay wait i got this i got this i will
win this battle i will win okay all right all right here we
go all right all right okay and then i grab my mask yeah
okay There you go.
This time.
This time's because obviously it's because I didn't wear the
right mask.
So he got a little angry.
Okay, now he's going to fall in love with me.
Yeah, now he's going to fall in love with me.
Hello.
We're the same.
You and I.
Ah!
I thought you said they...
I thought they said, like, we're friends.
They can fall in love with me.
That's it.
Oh, God.
Wait, wait.
I can shank him.
Yeah, kill him.
Kill him.
Shank him.
It's not working.
It is.
It's working.
It's an ogre.
No!
Oh, I have a call.
Let's answer that.
Major.
Snake, are you all right?
He's dying.
I'm okay.
You're far from okay.
Look at your life gauge.
No, I got this.
It's okay.
I got it.
Oh, God.
He's dying.
Oh, my God.
oh my god do you know what that means here no you don't uh
what it means there's no backup no cavalry if you're taken
out nobody okay why didn't he call me when i was drowning i
know we tried but you were drowning like you couldn't hear
it oh you know you oh yeah yeah yeah on the level of your
stamina gauge so get plenty to eat then get some rest you
hear me
here i wasn't prepared yeah yeah see i'm assuming position
oh wait what's that something i don't know what is that
something a present a bug juice oh yummy that's right
where's the crocodile now you should eat you should eat wait
did you already eat the snake yeah i ate a snake you can eat
the calorie man what's up wait where did my bug juice go uh
it's a item yeah oh what's that for I was fighting a fucking
crocodile, not fucking bugs.
Where the fuck is my crocodile juice?
Well, there is none, I don't think.
What the fuck?
I feel like crocodiles are much more dangerous than hornets.
No, I don't think crocodiles produce juice, but bugs produce
juice.
Okay.
Let's see.
We got this.
Okay.
Wait, wait, he's walking closer.
Whoa.
He's weak.
You're right.
You got him.
Okay, I go.
I mean, so are you.
You're also pretty weak.
I mean, it says 85%.
Oh, wait, that's my stamina.
That's your...
No, that's your camouflage.
Oh, that's my camouflage?
Okay, we'll eat this.
Yeah.
All right.
I want some more.
Stamina recovery?
All right.
Yeah, I should heal.
That'll heal you faster.
Yeah.
Still pretty slow.
I think I can get one more stab in.
I think so.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
Get him there.
Whoa, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You see that?
In and out?
Whoa, juction?
Oh, it's- We're Dark Souls?
Oh, shit!
Oh, okay, okay.
It's fine, it's fine, fine, fine, fine.
We're Dark Soul-ing.
It's like a Soul's like...
It seems like, what the get-er?
There you go.
It's like the POV, Crocodile POV.
Can you also make crocodile noises?
What the fucking crocodile sound like?
oh my god he's turning around weak he's weak he's turning
around you could shoot him and tranquilize him and then stab
him a bunch of times no that's fine i get his legs
i'm trying to find the hip box a little closer yeah closer
there you go closer oh oh he doesn't care he doesn't care he
doesn't care he doesn't care he's just like he's almost down
he's He's almost down.
He's weak.
He doesn't care about his legs.
He can't fight back.
He's weak.
Look at him.
Yeah.
Got his toes.
Look, he's screaming in agony.
His mouth wide open.
Yeah.
No one can hear you scream in the forest.
He's standlocked.
Oh, we did it.
Thanos got him.
Now take his meat.
I got GAVA, whatever the fuck that is.
Wait, is that the means?
Oh, okay.
So now I can eat.
Oh, shit.
Oh, not taste unknown.
Oh, I got to try it now.
Pretty tasty.
Pretty good.
Look at that.
Two for it.
I ate one ration and got three crocodile meat out of that.
Look at that.
Yeah.
Oh, there's another guy.
There's another guy?
No, I'll leave him.
I'll send a message.
Now I just want to be gold.
Okay, good.
Oh, my God.
Wait, it looks awesome.
Yeah.
And the glasses?
That's awesome.
I'm so cool.
Oh, my God.
Is that choice?
Yes.
Want to get across without...
Yeah, I know.
Want to get across without drowning.
All right.
How do I do that?
Just do it.
yeah i'll put my mask on just standing up wait i want to see
it oh my god good oh my god he looks like he looks like the
wild duckling of the jungle yeah meet this guy outside of
the park and they
oh my god can i wait can i live can i cross the spot can i
cross is fine yeah yeah yeah you can cross that oh there was
a grenade there okay that yeah did you grab it yeah yeah
yeah yeah there's another cross okay there you go okay yeah
keep going keep going don't stop i have minus 100 stuff i
don't understand how could they see me yeah i don't know
like i feel like you would be hidden in like i know right
raise of the sun them you know when they look at me they get
blinded by the gold oh that'd be so good I'm like Edward
Colin in Twilight where he sparkles in the Sun
wait my mask didn't show oh it's probably oh I think it's a
setting you have to enable oh my god look at him though
I look so cool.
I know.
Yeah, get that guy's ass.
Get that guy's ass.
Get the rasses.
I swear to enemy soldiers.
They're probably KGB troops sent to guard Sokolov.
AK-47s and grenades.
He looks so cool.
Yeah.
Oh my god, he's even shiny.
Like, there's like, those like statue people outside that
pretend to be like chrome statues.
contact with the enemy is strictly prohibited don't engage
them in battle like the people in new york yeah yeah yeah
you have to give them like give them like five dollars for
them to move yeah yeah yeah through the jungle without being
seen oh that's a bit hard yeah this is like a stealth game
just by the way and then you can go to gold you can go to
gold oh while the face option lets you change your face
paint Choosing camouflage that blends in with your
surroundings will help you conceal yourself more
effectively.
Also, don't forget that anything that moves will stand out
in the jungle.
Like, he just stands up and does a loop-a-loop.
But if you crawl instead, you should be able to sneak by
without being noticed.
You can see how effective your camouflage is by letting you
get the camo in.
Um, you know.
The camo index shows how well your current camouflage blends
in.
the higher the value oh yeah oh yeah every time every time
okay even though if i have minus 100 stealth it'll be fine
right they are literally gonna be blinded by that's true
that's true i'll be like a blind spot it would be like don't
worry about it all right or you could shoot them that's cool
too oh okay all right or you can hold them up and make them
wiggle oh i like that wiggle part okay how do i make it so
my masks will show Uh, probably.
Oh, show headgear during cutscenes.
Oh, nice.
I like that.
Okay, wait, why is there a huge warning sign?
Oh, I think it's because, like, yeah, you're immersion.
I don't know what they're talking about.
I'm very immersed right now.
I know if I'm wearing it, I want to see it.
Yeah, exactly.
Oh, I think someone just saw you.
No, it's fine.
They might shoot you.
Oh, they missed.
Oh shit, it hit me!
Oh shit!
Oh shit, oh shit!
Give me a sec!
I don't have any equip!
You could equip it like right now.
Okay, wait, wait.
I'll reset them.
Don't worry.
I got this.
Watch this.
Well, I don't know if they'll follow you.
Oh, wait.
Nice.
Oh, I was going to reset the whole thing.
It's like I just played the game again.
Yeah, there you go.
Alright.
I don't understand.
Why was he not flashbang?
He probably might be used to it In the forest Yeah yeah Okay
Or he's wearing sunglasses Don't worry I'm first person Oh
the red is like totally ruining your goal Oh my god I know
It's so bad Wait oh my god Wait I can Roll over snake Roll
over Roll over Oh
You know you could do that?
All you're doing is rolling very slow.
Slow motion roll.
It's the immersion.
This is the immersion.
I don't understand how he saw me.
I was in the tall grass like they told me.
I think because you're...
What the fuck?
I think because you're at negative 100.
There's no way.
Okay, it's fine.
We're here.
All right.
You could shoot them too.
Yeah, shoot them.
Can you walk the way?
Oh, they're going to bring more people.
Oh.
Don't worry, I'll reset it.
No.
No word.
False alarm.
Okay.
Test, take three.
Take three.
I might have to take off the gold.
But, okay.
What if, oh, naked woodland.
What does that look like?
Yeah.
Whoa.
Okay, I think...
Yeah.
This one has like a giant.
You bought the gold and you're not going to wear it.
Like, what a waste of money.
Okay, but like, I will.
I'll wear it after this.
Okay.
All right, wait.
Okay, and then I feel like the frog is the best for it.
The frog, yeah, I can touch it.
There we go.
So those, the frog mask and the duck mask in every area,
like every map, there's a hidden frog and then hidden duck.
Oh.
That's cool.
All right, so where are they?
I don't know.
Use your eyes.
Stand tall.
You see, I see there's a little hole at the top.
I know.
I'm looking through it.
Up a little higher.
We'll be able to see it soon.
Oh, my God.
They saw me from that.
Okay, shoot him.
Shoot him.
Shoot him!
I'm trying to find him!
Wait, wait, wait!
You see him?
Oh, yes, yes.
Right here?
Right there?
Yeah.
You think I got him?
Wait, wait.
I think he... Oh.
Wait, did that actually?
I got him!
First try!
Okay, so your trank does run out, by the way.
Oh, okay.
Or not the trank, sorry.
Your suppressor.
Your suppressor does run out.
Okay, okay.
First try.
How do I drag this guy?
Uh, you gotta stand up.
You gotta, like, not be clipping into his bud.
Okay, what if I just stab him?
Oh, yeah, you could kill him.
You can do that.
Okay.
Keep going.
Alright.
Okay, that's just a strong-ass tranquilizer.
Yeah.
It's probably made for, like, blow or something.
There we go.
We did it.
All right.
Now you gotta hide the body.
Don't forget there's another guy.
I don't think he saw me.
Oh, hey.
Nice.
Oh, nice.
How do I take him?
You just pick him up and drag him away.
Can I bring him to the crocodiles?
I think you'll drop him before you do that.
Yeah.
that's unlucky but you could put him in the grass oh it's
kind of peaceful there yeah he's one with nature all right
okay so the only problem with the frog mask is that it might
be hard to aim with it maybe i'm not that i don't know i
don't i i'm not that sure yet but it might be a little Yeah,
it's a bit hard to tell because there is a hole on the top.
There is a hole on the top.
Yeah.
It's like, it's like, yeah, part of it makes it easier and
part of it makes it a little more difficult.
Yeah.
I say it's on the easier side, but I'm a trained player.
So yeah, yeah.
I get it.
I get that.
Yeah.
Oh, I can grab him.
Wait, where is he?
Oh, that's your CQC.
There he is.
I'm going to try grabbing him.
Do I have to be not prone to grab him or no?
You have to be not prone.
Oh my god, but if I stand up, he'll see me Yeah, that's the
stealthy part.
Yeah, I got this
Where is he?
Oh, there he is You see him?
Yeah.
Oh, yeah, no sneak up behind him Oh Wait, what the okay.
Sorry You think he saw me?
Oh shit.
Oh my god Can you say there was more?
than two guys what the they lied to me they lied you that's
actually four uh yeah i forgot to tell you that part but
it's okay you you got him down it's fine there's a kettle
time it's a kettle they're gonna wake up by the way soon so
oh oh you're killing him yeah a good thing you're
I'm just giving him a little treat.
Is he dead?
Oh, yeah, he's definitely dead.
I've been stabbing for way too long.
I thought he'd disappear.
Okay.
It's like if snake were sensitive to blood.
All right.
You keep going, keep going.
There you go.
Keep going till there is.
There it is.
It's good that he died.
Wait, where's the last guy?
You could just keep going.
You don't have to kill him.
They will respawn, by the way.
Like, no matter if you kill them or not.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Do the combo.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, my God, you guys, her river is going to be nuts.
She's laughing, but she doesn't know what that means.
All right.
There's still one more guy.
Where is he?
Oh, no, I think you got him.
I got all of them?
I think so.
Oh, there was one more guy.
No, no, no.
I thought, oh, there's the frog!
Yeah, if you shoot him, he makes a noise.
Yeah, where's my...
Hold, hold it, yeah.
All right, there you go.
All right, now shoot him.
There's the tree in it.
Okay.
There is a tree in front of it.
Well, maybe move.
Oh!
It's called keraton!
Yeah!
Wait, can I take him or no?
No, he's just there.
Oh, he's just there?
Yeah, he's just chilling.
All right, I gotta pee real quick.
Give me a sec.
I'm here.
All right.
Get me with him.
Okay, well, did you take care of that guy?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I killed all of them.
Hey, I'll be right back.
Okay.
Guys, did she...
Did she take care of all of them?
I don't know if she did.
She didn't pause.
She missed one.
That guy's going to be awake.
She didn't pause.
He might not patrol over here.
Probably not.
I want her to kill so much so that...
that when she gets to the sorrow it'll be great yeah
actually all the animals too everything yeah grow her horn
nice and big that's stealth oh part of me like wants to move
the camera but like i can't you know because i i'm not i'm
not playing the game i like watching kero tan spin though
it's kind of cute hello i'm back hello hello welcome back
all right where do i go now wait hush right we will say
nothing what are they taught i don't know wait you go to the
okay turn around okay go here to the to the right to the
right to the right it's crazy everything is just green how
do you navigate yeah and imagine the first game like the
original it was so much worse because it was like PS2
graphics so you're like oh so it's even more confusing oh no
I could take it off right now you could you could yeah wait
all right yeah all right Off, off, there you go, yeah.
Yeah, there you go, there you go.
You have to RB, you see what he's looking at.
Oh, it's the Hornet!
Oh, that's such a cool, it's- Oh.
Oh, that's a cool feature though.
I wish I could do that, like, okay.
Okay, let's do what?
I wish when I pressed RB, I can see.
I can think you can see.
Okay, so he's right under the beehive right now.
What are you going to do?
I shoot the beehive.
Well, he's not under it.
He's not under it.
I'm waiting.
Oh, okay.
Once he's under it.
Where is he?
Oh.
Wait, where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Go, go, go, go.
Oh my God.
Oh, my God.
Oh, he passed it.
He passed it.
I gotta wait.
No, it's not.
Go, go, go.
Yeah, go.
Oh, there's like, yeah.
Oh, it flies over.
It did a loop.
Yeah.
Oh, no, he's running.
Oh, he's going to bring the bees over.
Yeah.
He's bringing the bees.
All the guys are running.
All the guys.
Okay, now's your chance.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go,
go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go,
go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
How do I get back up?
Pull yourself up.
How do I...
Oh.
B.
No, that's let go.
I read that thing.
Like they said, I just...
I think it's triangle.
Oh, oh, I'm doing a pull-up.
Two.
Three.
Bro, that arm game is weak.
Okay.
Kill him this time.
Alright.
That guy, he's actually allergic to these.
Okay, I don't understand.
My crosshair was on top of it.
It just happens.
It has like a fucking tilt over it.
Yeah.
Like it tilts.
Yeah, I have noodle arms.
they're gonna run away yeah i'll just head over all right
don't fall off okay now that i know hanging new style oh uh
oh oh press i did press a clearly not good enough yeah
bullet drop yeah there's ball yeah there's bullet drop what
the okay okay okay okay b b b b no no no no no no no no no
There we go.
Wait, which way was it?
Other way.
Okay, I lost track.
Alright, here we go.
I didn't fall off this time.
Can I...
Can I pillage the mushroom?
Yeah, yeah, can I?
Yeah, you can get them.
How do I get them?
Uh, yeah, like that with your knife.
You can equip your knife.
Alright.
There must be a faster way to equip it.
Oh.
There you go.
Yeah!
There's some more.
I'm so hungry.
Yeah, my stomach is grogling.
Oh my ass.
Alright, let's try the mushroom.
Yeah.
I shouldn't kill you.
Oh, nice.
Not so great.
Bakers can't be choosers, snake.
You're in the forest.
Well, he can still have an opinion.
No.
Wait.
Yeah, that way.
I heard number B's.
okay but what if I just shoot from here should be fine the
bees there's no way the other you forgot to get the other
one yeah but I'm just thinking like there's no way the bees
will chase after me I'm so far away yeah yeah see it's fine
and then pillage them yeah okay let's go this way yeah Oh,
it's so annoying to swap between the two.
Yeah, more mushrooms.
More mushrooms.
Let's eat more mushrooms.
I'm so hungry.
Yeah, they're everywhere.
What is this?
He just hates it.
You are causing it.
On your right.
It's like those hikers passing each other.
bye just passing by guys I knew they were gonna come back
soon but damn just okay sokolov is in there okay just so
yeah that's the the guy with the ugly wife yeah okay so they
have him underneath like the house Okay, so it's the
basement.
Yeah.
I wonder how many are inside.
Your objective, Sokolov, is inside the factory.
They should be holding him in a room in the northeast
section.
Northeast section.
Got it.
Be careful.
Your mission is to bring- What happens if I kill him?
He must not be exposed to any kind of- I can't?
No.
Oh.
Also, put your mask, put the mask back on.
Okay.
there's more no it's just that when you get to circle off i
want you to tell him tell him what and that is they have a
relationship oh they're gay understood beginning my approach
it's a lavender wedding oh marriage all right let me put the
mask back on yeah the mask stays on the mask stays on nearby
tree.
Press against it.
Oh, okay.
Well, against surface.
Make noise.
Yeah, you can knock and stuff.
I don't think they hear me.
No, I don't think so.
Alright.
Just a win, I guess.
Oh, maybe if I'd make it against this wall.
They're kind of far, though.
Knock, knock.
They're letting you in.
Maybe there's no one in set.
It's a good beat.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum,
bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
All right.
Maybe this one.
Wait, where is he?
They're all over.
Oh, right here.
Oh, my God.
They can't hear anything.
We're in a den for some shit.
Oh, wait, wait.
No, he's got his.
He got his earbuds in there.
Oh, he has his earbuds on.
That makes sense.
Yeah, yeah.
What do I do with this guy?
Kill him.
You didn't see him?
He's, oh, he saw me.
There you go.
Oh, I think he already called for backup.
Oh.
And now they're calling for more backup.
Yeah, it really sucks when they start radioing.
Okay, I, okay, I, okay, that's what do you mean?
Okay.
Yeah, um...
Oh!
Whoa.
Wait, how many people are here?
Uh...
Great question.
Wait.
Oh my god.
Oh, nice.
I have cutscene immunity.
Bro!
Oh, shit!
Nice.
It's okay.
Yeah, the game pauses, like, when you're, like, switching.
Bro!
Wait, where did he go?
That's where I got you!
Oh, shit.
Wait, he got me.
I got you.
Okay, wait, I...
Oh, I got a shotgun!
Oh, you got a shotgun!
Use that, use that!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Where is it?
Oh, you gotta equip it for him.
God damn it.
Wrong.
Oh, my God.
I can't...
Okay, there you go.
Yeah, there you go.
Okay, okay.
Uh...
The M-37.
Yeah.
Yeah, and then...
And then equip it.
Yep.
Okay, now stand up and shoot.
Or you can just shoot one down.
Yeah, that's good.
There you go.
I think he's dead.
Yeah, and then your alert's going down, too.
They have no idea where you're at.
Yeah, they don't know.
They're stupid.
They're so dumb.
I know, right?
Okay, there's a lot of people now awake.
Oh, oh, oh, get his ass.
Yeah.
Oh, I think three guys were alerted.
It's okay.
Can't get me.
Can't see out there.
Okay.
You don't need to see me.
Yeah, it's so true.
Wait, he sees me from there?
Oh, no.
Just shoot him.
Yeah, just shoot.
Oh my god, that's a grenade.
Yeah, they're pretty hardcore sometimes.
Yeah, they don't know where I am.
They'll get worse.
Yeah, in the actual mission.
Yeah, I could...
It's like a sniper.
Watch this.
I see him.
Oh, wait.
He's still alive.
Oh my god.
He tanked that.
Yeah.
Wait, blow those up.
Shoot the, shoot the barrel Oh, this bear?
Oh, shit!
Did I get him?
I think I got him.
Oh, I think so.
Oh, my God.
I did it.
The other guy out, too.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Oh, wait.
Wait, this guy's alive.
Okay, give me a sec.
That guy's alive.
Take him out.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Shoot, shoot, shoot.
Oh, where I got you.
I got this.
Actually, stab him.
Stab him.
Save the...
No, no, no.
Oh, okay.
Okay, I think he's dead.
You, like, I have to dramatically flail his arm.
Guys, I think I got him, guys.
No survivors.
I wanted to alert them, guys.
If I alerting...
Oh, I want to see you guys.
Oh, yeah, nice.
By alerting them, I get to kill more people.
Wait, he's just asleep.
How are you asleep?
I fucking shot you.
Um, are they still around?
I don't know.
I don't know how they're alive.
I shot them.
Well, they'll wake up eventually.
You could just go to Sokolov.
I just got him.
There we go.
Yeah.
Okay.
Do you have shotgun ammo?
No.
I'm giving them pat down.
What's this?
Oh, nice.
I don't know what that is.
That will disable like their comms.
Oh, wait.
I like that.
Yeah.
All right.
I think we did it.
there's like the music and i heard someone talking but i
don't know yeah i heard that too i'm scouting at the top
literally no one here no witnesses guys no witnesses there's
a roof guy not yet oh oh oh kill him hold him up hold him up
oh or that oh i how do hold him up you have to like oh look
he you have to just aim oh he had an accident in his pants
he started a little oh it's so embarrassing it's so
embarrassing for him oh in front of everyone oh We all saw
him.
Yeah, we all saw you.
I scared the shit out of him.
And I smell it.
I smell it too.
It's like so bad.
Man, that's so embarrassing.
You're gonna find his body like that too.
Yeah.
And he's just gonna, his reputation will be tarnished
forever.
Hmm.
Oh, is that him?
Sokolov.
Yeah, sokolov.
Look at that he's burning.
He's burning the paint blue!
America needs them!
He burned it all!
He burned it all.
That's so smart, because all the blue players is in his
head, so they have to keep him alive.
Yeah.
You're CIA.
Trust me.
Zero.
The man who got you out two years ago.
i have a message from him what is it he said to tell you
sorry for being so late he kept him waiting did he now what
does it mean it means sorry for being so late oh he promised
to save he owes him one you have to get me out of here
before they arrive who's they oh man who's there they it's
they got him it's they thunderbolt i feel like he's always
just confused all the time he's like thunder paramedic
thunderbolt naked snake that's like his thing has been
pursuing a policy of peaceful coexistence with the west
nothing bad ever happens to the kennedys because he's still
alive right
but the failure of his agricultural policies has put him in
a precarious position and on top of that the tragedy last
November the president Kennedy's assassination oh yeah he's
dead but nothing bad ever happens to the Kennedys oh my god
meant spoilers They just said it.
That's your guy.
That's our guy.
Oh.
Colonel Vulgan.
Thunderbolt.
Yeah.
Much like this one.
OKB812 known as the Grunin Design Bureau and is using it to
further his plans.
But he was alive and cloned high.
I think that was his clone.
No way.
Is that what clone high is about?
Yeah, it's about like cloning historical figures and Putting
them in high school.
Oh, my God.
That's the whole point of Clown High.
They chose him?
Is it because he couldn't object?
Because nothing bad ever happens to the Kennedys.
Exactly.
They wouldn't need that many men just to keep me inside.
Their orders were to prevent Colonel Vulcan from capturing
me.
Even if it meant killing me in the process.
That's not capturing.
Vulcan will come.
I'm sure that you must get me out of here before then.
Leave it to me.
I love Vulcan.
I never read of that character before.
I'm speaking Russian?
Yeah.
I'm like, yeah.
Excuse me.
This is it.
English.
It's funny because there's not even a Russian dog.
Yeah, it's like...
Having second thoughts.
No.
I have no love for this place.
Let's go.
What about your wife?
Are we just leaving her?
No, I don't think she's here.
Oh, we'll just leave his wife in Russia.
Yeah, yeah.
Like, when the fuck when I was...
When did I speak Russian?
We've been speaking Russian.
He's doing fine.
No injuries.
Good work, Snake.
Now hurry up and get Sokolov to the recovery point.
We'll rendezvous with you there.
We'll rendezvous.
What about the centuries?
I had to kill them.
There was no other way.
But no one will know we were involved.
Yeah, there was no other way for me to kill them.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I had no other...
You just had to.
I had to, you know?
Yeah.
They forced me.
They did force me.
sure yeah exactly okay I don't know if you like playing
games but like playing the game but yeah I don't know if you
like playing games yeah okay yeah and what what about it
you'll see I mean just like enjoy the movie I guess oh my
god he comes oh my god oh is it thunderbolt comes oh my god
thunderbolt what the is he gonna do all he has is his head
so he's shielding the shot he's like is he trying to call me
coming huh just yeah he is coming yeah oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
isn't it it's a yaoi yaoi it's a yaoi oh that's just oh my
god don't you i thought you killed all of them yeah i
thought so too without a self-defense is
it octopus oh it's awesomeness yeah that's my boy that's my
boy oh my god he's gonna flip his guns
How many snakes has Ocelot banged?
He's loyal to only one.
What?
How come he's paired up with all the snakes?
He's not paired up with all the snakes.
He's paired up with the wrong.
Wait, there's...
Hold on.
He's the Ocelot commander.
Just... Okay.
Only when he puts on the hat.
They don't...
That's how they recognize him.
Look at him spin.
Don't recognize him until he puts his hat on.
Ocelot.
Get out of here.
Oh my god.
That's major Ocelot.
What?
Oh.
He's killing his fellow moon.
Wait, why?
Is he a traitor?
He took his hat off.
He won't recognize him!
It's like Superman.
He's like, bury the platypus.
Oh my god, he's...
Whoa!
Oh my god, he saw a geometry.
He'll never guess what he does next.
He shoots him.
Hustler?
Major Hustler?
After he deals with this guy?
After he deals with this guy.
He puts on a hat.
And then they'll go, Major Ocelot.
Major Ocelot.
I can't say it feels good to kill a comrade.
Even if it is for the crew.
Soak along.
Take cover.
Call in the army.
He's gonna tug him.
He's gonna kiss him?
Is he gonna...
You're not the boss, are you?
That's what he does.
I told you you wouldn't guess.
That's why he's called us a lot.
He's a cat boy.
Yeah.
If you're not the boss...
Then die.
His gun jammed!
Oh yeah, his gun's jammed!
Oh, guess I'll kill him.
Okay.
What do we do?
Wait, what if I just stabbed him?
Why did he say shoot the other one and then ran at him and
didn't shoot him at all?
Why are you all just running?
Oh shit.
Just shoot him Just shoot him It doesn't matter He's not the
major Okay I like how they all just waited One by one
They're scared They're not gonna mess Okay would you mess
with a crocodile man Yeah Frog match Oh You just feigning
What happened to him I think you like Choked a man Oh shit
Oh, he doesn't have his hat on.
I don't know who he is.
Oh,
I tranked his arm.
Oh, yeah, because it's not a real gun.
Oh, my God.
Here's where the yaoi comes.
But testing a technique you've only heard about.
The yaoi.
You were asking to have your gun jam on you.
Besides, I don't think you're cut out for an automatic
weapon.
You tend to twist your...
Oh.
He's doing an um actually on him.
I know.
You filthy American dog!
Enemies to lovers!
But that was some fancy shooting.
You're pretty good.
Pretty good.
Do you see it?
Do you see the vision?
I see the vision.
I understand.
I saw him.
It gets worse.
I saw him firmly grasped his arms.
Apparently they were taking orders from a Gru Colonel named
Vulgan.
A Gru Colonel?
Part of an internal Soviet force team, according to Sokolov.
Something between the KGB.
It's like spy versus spy.
Yeah.
Sokolov was being guarded by the KGB and hunted by Gru.
Snake, it sounds like this could be even hotter than Cuba.
I don't like it.
Something about the whole thing stinks.
I agree.
You'd better hurry.
Sokolov ran off by himself.
All right, you ready for an escort mission?
Oh, fuck.
Not an escort.
I'm not a fucking escort.
I'm just kidding.
Oh, thank God.
Okay, wait.
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
What happens if I...
I created the time paradox.
You created a time paradox.
Okay, but what if...
What if...
Uh-huh.
Time paradox.
Okay, okay, now that I know it.
So remember how I said that this is the first in the
timeline?
Yeah, you see Ocelot in the first game.
Oh, so he's not supposed to be dead.
That's why it's a time pair, though.
Okay, I gotta...
I gotta make sure they don't wake up.
Oh, okay, wait, I can...
Yeah, they don't wake up here.
You can do whatever you want.
Oh, I can?
Oh, okay.
They'll never wake up.
Oh, that's good.
Okay, so I don't have to actually kill them.
I want to see if he has items.
Yeah, I know.
I mean, I might as well.
No survivors.
Except for him, I guess.
I guess he survives.
He's like...
Oh, oh, it took us one more!
Wait, I want...
Can I kick them to death?
I can't put any of those.
Okay, let's see where I kick it.
okay wait I got me here I got me here he's not I'll keep him
alive I'll keep him alive still never have children the end
of his blood yeah I ended his blood life all of his friends
are dead one last kick for the ride before I go
okay back where I came from right oh wait I should call I
gotta call my dad give me a sec I call my dad give me a sec
what if he's proud of me the KGB and Gru both have their
sights set on Sokolov Gru is a military espionage outfit the
intelligence wing of the Soviet Defense Ministry's general
staff office It competes with the KGB, which is under the
Ministry of Internal Affairs, and the two are always
watching each other.
Okay, but he's not, did he not see what I just did?
That's your job.
You want a pat on the back every time you do your job?
I want a medal of honor.
You'll give one.
And Vulcan and the anti-cruise chair forces are using the
groom.
That's the idea.
The two factions are fighting over Sokolov.
We're in an extremely...
Wait, what is the difference between the KGB and Gru?
They're just different factions, basically.
But they're all under Russia, though.
Yeah, but I mean, it's like if the CIA and the FBI started
beefing.
Yeah, but why are they beefing?
I don't know.
They're just beefing.
Where is my lord up, Mint?
Thought you're the Metal Gear Encyclopedia.
He explained it.
Excuse me, my Metal Gear Encyclopedia is not working quite
well.
I don't know history.
There you go.
You're gonna be.
Spits knives.
Oh, also that?
Yeah.
Why doesn't he trust me?
Does he think I'm crazy?
with the frog mask um no he does trust you he's just really
scared because he's a weenie oh he's from weenie hut junior
wait that's a cannon is this another movie time rb rb rb oh
oh oh oh god that i put my hands down the controller because
i was like movie time yeah they um they trick you with that
and without support from friendly units oh oh That's the
Shaggle Hogs.
Whoa!
The Shadow what?
The Shaggle Hog.
Oh, I thought it was like Shadow Hog?
Shadow the Hedgehog?
Shadow the Hedgehog.
Phase one?
It won't be truly finished until we complete.
Phase two.
The weapon's true form.
If it is completed and the Colonel gets his hands on it, it
will be the end of the Cold War.
That's good, right?
Oh, wait, but for not America.
Yeah, that's not good for America.
I didn't want to die.
I wanted to see my wife and child again.
Oh, no.
Oh, they're in America.
Yeah.
Cannot complete it without my help.
That's why they had to keep him alive.
yeah okay
you don't get to play the game okay okay my hands are not on
the controller don't worry
it's like a movie watch a lot with the dragoons and the
whiffs
this guy's afraid of everything it's a bridge yeah because
he's a nerd he doesn't go outside we're just getting kind of
silent oh yeah oh oh my god so foggy now it got dark real
quick is it winter i know it's russia whoa who's that the
boss quiet no it's the boss oh it's the boss okay
the oh her name is lori allen Your name is boss Oh shit Why
is she trying to kill him Is she a traitor?
She's just pulling a little prank Good work Jack What are
you doing here?
Sokolov Comes with me Oh Oh Not the bees
Whoa Oh my god Bees There's so many bees Oh my god So many
bees Oh my god They're at the bees!
What are they track?
What the fuck?
Say hello to your bosses of the game.
He controls the bees?
Bees B-Man!
Bro, it's like if Spider-Man has the power to shoot spiders
out of his hands.
No, that's spiders, man.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, I remember this natural character in
the Marvel universe.
Yeah, he's bees, man.
My friends, let us fight together again.
The Cobra unit.
The fear.
Bro, why are their codenames so cool?
The pain.
Yeah.
Bro, why isn't he not bees, man?
The end.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Now it's raining.
What the fuck is happening in Russia?
What the fuck is...
Welcome to Metal Gear.
Yo, what's going on in Russia right now?
It's like the fucking...
What is it called?
Like the story in Moses where it started raining.
blood oh yeah something something like that what the fuck
ghosts are real oh wait you're you're here I'm literally
right here cool bar oh thunderbuck so basically the
president of Russia is fighting against this guy for yeah
yeah oh so she is Is a traitor.
Ah, what a joyful scene.
Oof.
Colonel Vogan.
Welcome to my country.
And to my unit.
Yeah.
Yeah, she just betrayed.
I knew it.
I knew I couldn't trust her.
I'm defecting to the Soviet Union.
Sokolov is a little gift from my new hosts.
Recoiless nuclear warheads.
That recoiless nuclear warheads is insane.
save what the fuck these will make a fine gift bro this
can't be happening who is he another one of your disciples
oh my gosh she a baddie oh yeah she is she's like the baddie
this one is still just a child too pure for us cobras oh the
entire unit was the cobra unit yeah wait so they took the
entire cobra unit?
Mm-hmm.
It was only just them.
He must have really good dental.
Oh,
he has to die now.
Don't need...
What are their photos of him?
I know, right?
Yeah, I was gonna say There were.
That's a good boy.
Yeah, it's like there's photos of you already, bro.
What the fuck are you talking about?
Everyone's seeing your face.
They were photoshopped.
He must die.
Oh, that's true.
He has to see shit with that mask.
That's so true.
There's no IOs in that mask.
you can't come with us you can't sit with us you're too
young you're bro you broke his arm you can't shake hands
right now he's like in his 30s by the way he's too young
oh the fake out oh no but that's his mom he's like mommy
It's because he looks so stupid
He didn't he didn't pass the test Back to back to us and
find It's like when a crocodile is released from the zoo See
you later alligator
Bro, yeah, he wanted to defect too.
He's like you're right.
Gotta follow mommy
My place is with them now I don't think he can hear you yeah
so what the does the parrot guy do like what why is the
special power is fucking bulging his eyes like um he uh he's
a sniper oh bulging your eyes does not make you snipe better
it could you don't know you can't do it
your codex going off
it's like when you extend your neck and you can see yeah you
see further away You bulge your eyes and you can see it
further.
I think it makes absolute common sense.
Yeah, like the fucking two centimeters further.
That's everything!
That's everything in sniping.
Oh yeah, welcome to healing.
Oh, nice.
I thought eating would heal me.
Well, it's like not really healing, it's like treating your
wounds.
Alright.
Okay, snake, just relax and it'll all be over before you
know it.
Stay with me.
I've seen people in worse shape before.
Think you can handle it?
Bro, he has a broken arm.
Major.
She messed him up.
Yeah.
She's defected.
We'll talk about that later.
First, we've got to get you patched up.
Why is they're not like, they're like unfazed by that.
If you select cure, you can start the treatment.
I can just cure my arm.
It is divided into two types of treatment.
Medicine and surgical procedures.
They did surgery on a grape.
Fractured left elbow and rib bone and lacerations on your
upper arms, right elbow and abdomen.
They need to be fixed using surgical treatment.
Move the healing cursor with a movement stick to the
affected part of your body and press the inner button.
Once you've selected the affected area use the movement
stick to select the medical item and then press the inner
button.
With this method you can use items to help your recovery
process.
bone fracture first secure the affected area with a fastener
oh my god am i playing like the trauma center right now what
the it's not it's not even like a press of a button it's
pretty it explains it'll be like this thing will will take
out a bullet this thing will is for good for burns let's you
know oh my god i gotta make sure i use the right medicine oh
i'm not okay I'm not okay All right, cure time Okay Cure
time All right, let's see your life Okay Wish to treat Jesus
Christ All right I have Oh my god I do not know Medical
history All right Cut bone fracture Bone fracture Wound is
still open Don't read that last super chat It has spoilers
okay don't spoil in a super chat that's like the worst you
can do um what's it useful for moving oh we had no i didn't
realize i actually used it okay so i i might be yeah that's
what it means to use it i might be with leeches no no the
cigar you don't have you have unlimited of oh okay thank god
i burned myself for no reason yeah it's fine so we can feel
a little more alive yeah yeah yeah okay wound is still open
um yeah you have to read you do have to read okay here
disinfect it okay i sanitized it okay nice nice and then
i'll put a band-aid and then i'll suture it oh yeah i put
band-aid and then i sutured on top of the band-aid um and
then i did it i'm fixed now and then the bandage because it
says no bandage applied okay and now don't worry i sutured
it for first and then i'll disinfect the the you were like
wasting so much stuff wait i am yeah how just do just do
what what what is the check mark yeah now you need to stop
the bleeding you can do it in any order yeah yeah yeah yeah
all right bandage not yet stable oh that's the split there
you go i fixed my broken arm okay so bandage Okay, another
splint and another bandage.
Jesus Christ, what is wrong with me?
Okay.
There you go.
Yeah, there you go.
Okay.
Bleeding.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
I trauma-centered it.
Yeah, yeah.
You're almost done.
I'm okay now.
Yeah!
You forgot the cigar.
Oh, that's true.
You are a duck.
or not oh oh
yeah so i don't fight my tongue that's why i do that yeah
i did it i fixed my arm it's no longer broken yeah i think
that's how that works yeah
he took her bandana i guess it made a really good sling
though yeah he's so resource job snake is you she's just
listening into my fucking groaning good job you did it you
made new mommy proud
is there a kid he has a new mama
i think the old mama didn't want to play with him anymore
I don't feel I feel like it would take more than four
helicopters to carry that yeah There's no way that
helicopter ain't fucking crashing into a mountain.
I know look at it.
I like the way its arms are dangly
Wait, what was your frequency?
I'm gonna call her You can I should call her while I was
doing my wounds.
I
goodbye old mommy goodbye they're so conflicting bye
you'll come back ray i
wonder how long the cutscene has been going it's just a
watch a lot him he's still holding the bullet that got
ejected from his gun oh my god he's like this should have
been in his body yeah he's obsessed yeah But they don't know
who he is yet.
He isn't wearing a hat Honestly, no they do know they do
know they have special vision.
Oh, okay.
I was gonna say it's only the soldiers.
Yeah Oh, I get it.
I get it.
Yeah, so like they can see through it's like they don't get
parry the platypus Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah
Thanks to the boss and her cobras I have both Sokolov and
the Shagohad Just found his soulmate so he doesn't know what
to do Wait, is that her?
Is that the boss?
No, no.
This is someone else.
What are we going to do with the girl?
Who's the girl?
Yeah, even he doesn't know.
This is Sokolov's woman.
Wait, that's the wife?
I thought you said she's ugly.
In Seoul.
She's a nice catch.
I'll take her.
Not so fast, my dear.
Wait, Sokolov's cheated?
Yeah, he's kind of icky.
I can't believe him.
That's why he sent his family to America.
So that he could cheat.
Oh my god.
She was.
gonna kiss a death him oh she should not should put she
should put the lipstick like another time there was time she
made it so obvious yeah she's a very bad assassin we should
we let her in the KGB I think it's time I gave this
marvelous she's what's so good he decided even if they are
our enemies there's still our countrymen but it won't be me
that Pulled the trigger.
Who is it?
Pulled the trigger.
Oh.
You want to nuke your fellow Russians?
Remember the Alamo.
The Alamo.
Okay, but it's...
Oh.
There it goes.
Boom.
Oh my god.
Remember, are you remembering the Alamo?
I'm remembering the Alamo.
Snake is still over here, just like...
Oh shit!
Get in the fridge, Snake!
I learned that and he had a choice!
He had a choice!
Buy the fridge, quick!
how the fuck is he surviving this radiation right now like
this actually happened he's just born different he's built
different data save yeah i'll save good job you've completed
the tutorial i did it i did the tutorial oh turn up the
music turn it up okay wait wait is that up enough
Wait, is that the song you like to sing all the time?
Yeah.
Oh, he turned it louder, yeah?
Yeah, but we won't be able to hear it a little bit.
You know what?
Maybe you shouldn't be watching us.
Actually, I don't think you should watch this.
Just listen.
Just listen to it.
I should close my eyes.
Yeah, I think you should close your eyes.
I forgot that the new version, like, of spoils i don't think
i would understand though even the spoilers come through i
guess that's better yeah yeah
oh my i remember this as well he's playing ace combat yeah
snake yeah eating that snake right now oh my god he has
pom-poms oh jesus fucking stupid bulge
This ordeal the trial to survive for the dead
We're real We're
real We're real, we're real I'm still in our dream Snake eat
up Bum Snake, Snake, Snake, you see her Snake eat up
Whoa!
One week later.
All right, let me turn it down.
Arriving
at the designated drone launch point.
Drone oil pressure and voltage are nominal.
Payload oxygen supply is nominal.
Power supply to payload any free system shows no problems.
No gusts.
All systems go for drone detachment.
Oh, that's me!
Wait, is my arm healed enough after a week?
Uh, apparently.
Yeah, I was gonna say, I don't think that's how bones heal.
Apparently, yeah.
Don't worry, they put me on a lot of steroids for this.
Okay, if you want to hold RB.
Yeah.
Just like hold it until like, you know.
Okay, I'm holding it.
Until like the end of the cutscene.
So how does it feel to be a patient in one of the most
advanced icus in the world whenever he's in the plan yeah
tell the suits about visiting hours i'll never get better
with them assault okay i turned it back to his original the
top brass's inquiry more like an interrogation according to
them i'm a traitor and an accomplice to the boss's defection
what i didn't know okay to be fair he was about to join a
defection she kicked them out let's just say neither one of
us is going to be made a national is going to die no this
fox is still one step ahead of the hounds the reason I came
to see you today Jack it's time for Fox to clear its neck
what are you talking about yeah what is he talking about Tom
we still got a chance has changed yeah what kind of chance
don't get too excited here have a cigar it's Cuban whoa nice
this morning I had a meeting with the CIA they decided when
they're going to execute us no something even bigger what's
the agent do the white house received an unexpected oh no
here it comes oh president johnson yes i hear you mr
chairman i hear you mr chairman it was a hotline call from
khrushchev to president johnson from the head of the soviet
union that's right a few days ago one of our design bureaus,
OKB 754, was destroyed in a nuclear explosion.
At about the same time, our anti-aircraft radar picked up a
signature that appeared to come from one of your military
aircraft.
Does any of this sound familiar to you?
In retaliation, I have placed our armed forces on secondary
alert depending on your response i may be left with no
choice but to order the military to maximum alert and
unleash oh because they blame the americans for nuking with
the yeah because it was an american yeah yeah able to
survive the cuban incident yeah but my power is not as great
as it once was yeah and this is a documentary survive this
crisis yeah yeah Yeah, I'm learning real history right now.
I should have contacted you myself.
I should have contacted you.
Can't believe you got the real President Johnson to voice
act this?
Like crazy, crazy.
I don't know.
So you haven't heard that.
The man who arranged the defection was a group colonel by
the name of Yevgeny Borosovic Volgin.
Volgin.
Of the Brezhne faction.
Go on.
who is the soldier her name is the boss she's a living
legend during world war ii she was the one who led us to
victory in that war in russia you know her as voyevoda you
mean voyevoda the boss yeah oh my god and she took two
miniature nuclear shells along with her the boss took two
miniature nuclear shells.
I'm afraid so.
I believe they were a gift for her new hosts.
The Davy Crockett Atomic Battle Group delivery system was
completed two years ago.
But serious problems were found with the launcher's range
and precision.
Although they were mass produced, they've never been
deployed in battle.
But Sokolos' research facility was completely wiped out.
The whole area is polluted.
Yeah.
Again, Snake lives through the radiation.
Condolences over this terrible tragedy.
So, they all live through the radiation.
Except the people that got hit.
Yeah, except for, like, the people who died.
The thousands of people that died in the research facility.
I wouldn't say thousands were in there.
Probably, like...
Maybe like one or two, you know.
Yeah, it was a pretty small thing.
Yeah, two people that forgot they forgot to notify.
Yes, that's correct.
American government denies any involvement in the affair is
that right as well that's correct we were not involved in
any way then what was a US military aircraft doing on our
radar screen it was clearly in a violation of our airspace
oh USA USA USA
else to tell you the army like the american flags while he's
talking about that say it again our government had nothing
to do with it and i would like dearly to believe however i'm
afraid my power i need not send an aircraft i will need some
kind of proof that this was not the action of the american
government you have one week you must catch the boss
yourselves and recover One week.
One week.
I have a deadline.
Then you can be home for Christmas.
Yeah!
Yes.
Preferably something painful.
Prove to me that this is not merely another one of your
tricks.
The boss should be close to Colonel Volgan.
Now about a little co-action.
I would not expect too much if I were you.
The political situation here is on stake.
Oh no.
And Colonel Vulcan is a member of the Brezhnev faction,
which seeks to topple him.
Yeah.
One week.
You have only one week.
And if it is not too much to ask, do something about Vulcan
as well.
It's been one week.
I don't know.
What happens if he doesn't do it in one week?
Means nothing.
Um, then...
Well, uh...
Like, does he have to?
It's not really that much of a threat.
If his government's gonna get toppled.
Yeah, do you want Volgan running the country?
He might be...
He might have, like, good policies.
You don't know that.
We don't know his policies, okay?
USA, USA.
Yeah, a new world war.
Oh, no.
World War III.
They've got something to cheer for a bit.
USA!
The boss ourselves will prove America's innocence.
The higher ups have decided that you're the only one capable
of pulling this off.
Me?
You were her last apprentice.
Screw this one up.
Who's her other apprentice though?
The one before me?
Should there be one before me?
You're the best one though.
Oh, heart hold RV now.
Okay.
Oh shit!
Look up.
Who the fuck is...
You mean Gucci?
Who is she?
Who the fuck is she?
There was a defection in September 1960.
You remember it?
Who is she?
That's the first of many women you will encounter in this.
situation their codenames are adam and eve oh adam and eve
yeah oh the rats with an escape route rats you'll need to
rendezvous with them when you get there
oh the russian planes are here
it's fast it's fast very sound i assume it'd be very fast
No, I swear.
Now we're actually playing Ace Combat.
Oh, yay.
Ace Combat time.
I think that's been like 80% cutscenes and 20% gameplay.
Maybe, yeah.
Hold.
Whoa.
Okay, the landing was not as cool as last time.
It's a little rough there.
He's like kind of beat up.
Yeah, yeah.
He took one week off.
Yeah.
My man's tired.
They like launched him out of the hospital bed.
Yeah.
He's probably like on so many medicines.
Oh yeah, pain medication.
He's just on the maximum limit of pain meds right now.
he's like I beat into it so it's a never-ending supply let's
go over your mission objectives one more time rescue Sokolov
find out the weapon to the shagahod then shagahod destroy
the shagohod not the boss not the boss that's where the
title drop oh my god I'm not a hired killer see they have a
photo of him what does it matter like you've seen my face
and we have like a fucking h4d for hd for a h4d everybody we
have an h4d photo of the man it's a brand new format of
photo Wait, he's changing his name?
He can just do that?
He picked the wrong one.
What the fuck?
See the movie, The Great Escape.
Okay, The Great Escape.
Anyway, it's based on a true story about prisoners who
escape from a POW camp in Nazi Germany.
The prisoners dig three tunnels as part of their plan, but
the Nazis find two of the tunnels before they're finished.
Prisoners succeed in escaping by using the last remaining
tunnel.
The names of those three tunnels...
were dick harry and oh does he want to be dick i get it you
use the name yeah escaped in as your he is that's exactly
right at least that was the plan but i got the name wrong
the one they escaped him was harry tom was one of the
unlucky tunnels it was discovered by the nazis before it was
finished i watched the movie again just to make sure well
you were asleep in the hospital he's just gotta get the code
name right you know 0.5 it was his fault it was his fault
yeah went bad because you know let's just use zero like
we've been doing all along oh and now he's changing it again
major zero it is we'll start over from square one major zero
no square zero my frequency what the okay okay remember that
i almost forgot snake has forgotten everything okay is this
her last chance too if we fail she'll have her medical my
god no she just can't work anymore what that's different she
can just get a different job not the same snake would die
she just loses the job that could be life or death for some
people she can't eat if she has no money she can't go in a
different field He only likes movies.
There's nothing else in her brain.
If you have any questions, just ask him.
His frequency is 148.41.
Oh yeah, sorry.
You missed Sigint.
Okay.
What does he do?
She tells you about weapons.
Okay.
He's cool.
I like him.
Okay.
The second factory Sokolov was being held in last week.
Yes, meet up with Adam first.
He's cleared the way for you to rescue Sokolov.
Oh, nice.
That's cool.
Yeah.
Does he look American?
the whole area has been what how do i know whose adam is you
just gotta you just you just gotta know oh wait you have to
say yeah oh it's your favorite lali lululelo yeah who are
the patriots lululelo be careful it's noisy but it doesn't
even mean i can't tell you that you're now on an official
mission of the united states my god i have 10 here now you
would know what it meant if you played metal gear solid 2
remember this is still a sneaking mission snake if you fail
this mission it will mean an all-out nuclear war oh no that
sounds bad yeah it's pretty bad maybe commencing operation
snake eater
oh my god we're here now we're back in the forest again i'm
playing the game again all right let's see wait what was the
frequency of my of my ex-mom you said i could call her you
can call her yeah i'm gonna call her what was her frequency
okay what was her frequency chat what was her frequency yeah
i gotta call my ex-mom maybe you know maybe she'll take me
back i'm literally next door what was her frequency guys one
four one dot eight zero one four one dot zero i almost got
it oh zero zero eight oh she's not picking up guys because
she removed my she she removed my number guys she changed
her number that's how you know it's official breakout oh no
she changed her number guys it's okay maybe maybe maybe her
no no no no no no her phone had zero battered her phone is
charging right now she used up her battery that's why yeah
yeah then wouldn't it you would still be able to leave a
voicemail no no it's like fully off she didn't have the
voicemail set up yet she didn't but she doesn't believe in
voicemails she doesn't do a rookie move like that yeah no no
she just she doesn't believe in voicemails because then uh
they can listen in you know yeah yeah yeah yeah she's smart
like that my mom's smart my mom my mom ain't no dumb me
everything i know look at that snake wait there's a way
there's a snake open the tree turn around you'll see him
turn around turn around turn around turn around turn around
turn around turn around down a little down a little down a
little turn around turn around how far are you seeing these
snakes are you talking about me there he is down i knew it
wait why why Where's my clothes?
Wait, they took my mask!
How could they do this?
No, they do!
Look!
They put the cigar back- Because your equipment limit is
reached.
You can- No, they put the cigar back in my pocket!
They dressed you back up.
Yeah.
It's okay.
There's no way there's people here.
All right, back to another cutscene.
Yeah, about that.
There's definitely people here.
No
She's so shiny In the moonlight it's kind of beautiful
It's out of moonlight
Looks like everyone's enjoying the watch along
It's gold chip Oh my god, it's gold chip What are you doing
here?
The mask is so bright.
I know.
Oh, shit.
I learned nothing, apparently.
Well, you were in the hospital.
She needs to give you a little bit of a break.
I know, right?
Mom, why didn't you answer my calls?
Go home.
She wants to, she wants to, she's like, what is she, oh my
gosh, she might have left the stove on and didn't realize.
Oh, yeah.
Sons?
What about me?
Am I not included in the sun's part?
I don't think so.
I think she hates you when you wear the mask.
Actually, these cutscenes are all different because she,
like, loves and accepts you if you're not wearing your mask.
But it's who I am, mom!
Oh my god, she revoked it.
It's like, don't call me, mom.
Don't call me, mom.
No, you're my one and only boss.
No.
This isn't America.
Oh.
Oh, she's pretending she's faking his death.
How much ammo is in that gun?
Jesus.
Like a lot.
That should stir things up a bit.
You'd better hurry.
Oh, no, it's raining.
The border is 60 miles south of you.
Oh.
You ought to be able to run that far.
Oh, no.
It's not coming off.
The paint's not coming off.
You're like the tin man from the Wizard of Oz.
What about you, Jack?
I'm gonna get like the fucking poison to my skin.
The mission or your beliefs.
Your duty to your unit or your personal feelings.
Mom.
I don't expect you to forgive me.
I miss you, mom.
Mommy.
Mommy, you don't even know how to get the paint off.
We're one week, mommy!
Whoa!
This part's so mean.
Oh no!
What the fuck?
She didn't have to do that.
No, what the fuck?
She's so mean!
She's like, go...
It's like, you know when there's like shows where they tell
like an animal to like go back go back to the wild when they
oh yeah yeah he's like i hate you go back to the forest go
back when when ash is butterfree or pikachu yeah yeah it's
like go back butterfree enemy scouts yeah i know but what
was the boss doing here in the first place there's got to be
a leak somewhere no that's impossible the man the boss is
working with vulgar and isn't exactly on speaking terms I
lost my gun the boss destroyed it snake I know how you're
planning on playing after this cutscene end we can call it
yeah that's how it is and if you don't accept it you'll
never be able to beat her that's not the problem in terms of
sheer technique I'll never be able to beat her I know that
all too well you've got to do it snake she's your enemy and
your objective enemy together for 10 Mommy!
Mommy!
Instead of my...
Get poisoned with the gold.
Whatever you do, don't let them see me.
Oh yeah, no, they definitely are gonna see me.
Oh yeah, they're like coming right now.
Yeah, yeah.
The gold.
You know, I think that's a good point to stop on because
I'm...
Did you see him?
There he is.
No, turn back around.
They're going to see you, like, immediately.
Turn the other way.
Oh.
Okay, wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
Let me...
I think you should save the game.
Yeah, and then give me a sec.
Maybe if I put this on real quick, and then put on...
I think they still see you.
What the?
Oh my god!
What hit me?
Oh my god, it's okay.
A man can hit you.
He kicked you.
It's okay.
See, look at that.
We're fine.
Oh my god.
Okay, that's safe.
How do I...
I think this is the perfect stopping point.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, can I call her?
Well, you could, yeah.
You could do whatever you want, honestly.
Paramedic.
Snake, it's so good to hear from you again.
Same here.
It's been a week, hasn't it?
Four days, actually.
Four days?
He said it was a week.
No, she visited him.
Oh.
Oh, she saw him naked.
Whoa.
That's like first base.
Why are they talking like this?
I believe that you were like that until just yesterday.
In fact, you really shouldn't even...
Better luck next time.
If you start to run low, don't push yourself.
Eat something to replenish your stamina.
And try not to get yourself hurt.
Try not to get yourself hurt, you know?
Go into the survival viewer immediately and treat yourself
using cure.
Yeah, yeah.
I can see you still know how to nag.
Oh.
And I can see you still don't know when to keep your mouth.
Whoa!
Also, by the way, I heard you're going to lose your medical
license if this mission fails.
Yes.
There was talk of that, but the mission won't fail.
Will it?
Of course not.
Good.
I believe in you.
But you know what?
See?
She doesn't care!
Didn't they use that to force you to participate in this
operation?
No, I volunteered.
Yeah, that makes sense.
I was going to be like, who cares?
Yeah.
Oh.
Oh, I didn't mommy accept me.
Why didn't she look?
Defect with her.
My mommy was better.
You can thank me when you get back.
Alright.
And then save.
Saving the game, Snake?
Yeah.
Everyone is trying to kill me, but I'll save my game.
Probably.
yeah she doesn't even tell you about a movie what the fuck
she just sends you back into the wild she just sends me back
i was like i'm dirt what about the movie fun fact i don't
even get a fun fact it has to be a fun fact yes please i
thought she was gonna look after me you just yeah but she's
not gonna tell me a fun movie fact oh you're in trouble what
i i have so much time to listen to movie trivia right now.
As I'm in like alert.
As like four people are trying to kill me.
I'm like come on, give me a movie trivia.
But that was fun for part one of Metal Gear Solid Delta
Snake Eater.
I had to think of it to remember the long ass title.
What do you think so far?
I think it's a very fun watch along.
I think I want to know, I want to know, like, well, I guess
I'll ask later.
I'm just going to say, like, what you're, what, I want to
know, like, what your predictions for the series are.
My predictions so far?
Well, obviously I'm going to kill her because I don't know
she existed as a character, right?
So, like, I feel like I'm, I know Ocelot is going to live
because I killed him and they're like, you can't do that.
That's a time paradox.
so I have no idea about the Vulcan guy I was like who the
fuck is that guy but like I'm like also I didn't know there
was the boss I guess after she dies big boss comes along and
takes over like that's where big boss is because the boss is
over so they need a successor and that's big boss and then I
assume that um paramedic becomes someone else later on too
because like maybe I don't know they seem quite quite close
and then um I I know there's more snake.
There's more than one snake, apparently.
So, I don't know.
Maybe this guy dies in this game.
And then another snake comes over and takes over.
Or like, or something.
Um, and, uh, that's all I know so far.
Oh, and then him and Ocelot kiss in the end.
Yeah, yeah.
Actually, that does happen.
They kiss in the end at the very end of this game.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Do you think I'm, do you think I'm like close to anything?
Actually, some of it is like pretty close.
Oh, nice.
But I'm not going to say what I'll find out later.
Yeah.
It is fun.
It's been fun.
I'm glad to bring my Metal Gear Solid Encyclopedia with me
for the ride.
Okay, so I was like, everything is correct, especially that
last part.
though it's really good will i be able to see it in this
game no oh oh so it's like a slow burn yeah oh okay you
don't even know it's like it's like a very slow okay but do
they kiss when they're super old men or like yes oh that's
how snow oh my god they're like in their retirement homes
and they're like finally i can confess to you the war is
over the cold war finally ended Yeah, pretty much
The cold war has ended I can finally confess my love to you
It's like It's the slowest burn Alright, I'm on Okay Alright
Well thanks for joining me for the ride Yeah, thanks, Doki
Yeah, I guess You're gonna keep, you're gonna finish the
game Right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah It's part of the charity auction to finish
the game how long did it take you to finish this game it's
not that long of a game but like how long did it take you oh
well i feel like you'll probably take about the same long as
me yeah because you're like you know you're fucking yeah
we're fucking around exactly it took me i have to go check i
don't remember someone said 15 hours oh that's not too bad
yeah yeah it's
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, it's fun, though.
It's been really fun, like, playing alongside with you.
And you told me, like, the little Easter eggs, dude, I would
have definitely missed a lot of the things.
Like, I would not have pressed RB.
I would not have seen the...
I would not have seen the random lady on top of my plane.
The thing is, like, you know, chat will, like, yell that at
you, usually.
They'll be like, RBRB, RBRB, but, like...
Yeah.
No, I would have, like, there's, like, stream delay.
So...
So I wouldn't have known.
Yeah.
But, yeah, thank you.
As long as you don't think I'm like being like, hey,
precious or whatever.
No, no, it's been, I think it's been really fun.
It's been really fun so far.
I haven't, I've been enjoying it.
I've been enjoying the mint back seating.
The little extra Lord dumps when I'm like, what the fuck is
going on?
Yeah, I'll give you like context for sure.
When I need the context, I'm like, I don't understand this
context.
but thanks for joining i had a great time man thank you for
for backseeding my very first metal gear game in the main
series this has been fun i hope you enjoy the rest of your
day during your travels yeah i'll see you oh i'll see i'll
see at the panel yes for those who don't know holiday maturi
doki and i have a panel yeah this this saturday at 2 30 p.m
est 2 30 p.m est Yeah, because I accessed a PSC and then the
organizers were like No, it's ESC!
Corrected!
I'm like, oh shit, sorry Oopsie She thinks in one time I
only think, yeah only one time zone exists for me Yeah,
Phantom Thieves panel Yeah, so if you're at Holiday Matsuri
We're gonna be doing a panel together It's gonna be a Q&A
guys, so you can ask us questions you line up and ask us
questions and we'll answer them we'll answer yeah we've been
doing a lot of stuff together the last two weeks which i've
noted yeah like the maid cafe this and now the holiday
material thing like back to back yeah a lot of good yeah you
guys are eating good today or the last two weeks you're all
eating good anyway we're i'm gonna call it we're gonna call
it here as always everybody stay hydrated posture get up and
move around get that blood flowing and you said for me head
to bed because you deserve it man you have any final words
you want to say to your the boo boo's uh the boo boy
the boo boy